when counting by fives starting from 170
hot when counting by fives starting from
179 which numbers will you say so let's
do that let's start with 179 and let's
count by fives so 179 plus five is equal
to what
well 179 one way I think about it 179
plus five is the same thing as 179 plus
one plus four and I added one just so I
get to 180 so this part right here is
equal to 180 so it's going to be the
same thing as 180 plus four so it's
equal to 184 now let's keep going so
let's just put we start at 179 then we
go to 184 then if we want to add 5 to
that
well 184 plus 5 we add five in the ones
place we get 189 now if we add 5 again
we're going to do with just what we had
over here 189 189 plus 5 that's the sum
same thing is 189 plus 1 plus 4 189 plus
1 is 90 or 190 plus 4 is 194 so this is
going to be 194 and then if you add 5
you're going to get 199 I just added the
5 to this 4 here in the ones place now
if you had 5 again let's see 109 this
would be 199 plus 5 is the same thing as
199 plus 1 plus 4 so 199 plus 1 is 200
plus 4 is 204 so let's see which of
these numbers we see so far so we saw
184 we see 189 we didn't see 186 we saw
194 we saw 199 and we saw 204 and we are
done